and the international olympic committee
has just announced the next city chosen
to host the 2030
summer olympics uh will be brisbane
brisbane will of course be the third
australian city to host the games
melbourne first had it in 1956 then
sydney played host in 2000 well for more
on this
across now to andy richardson who joins
us now from inside the tokyo 2020
media center and it looks like the show
must go on despite all the recent
difficulties
and it's brisbane's turn for the
spotlight
well nothing ever happens involving the
olympics without an element of
controversy normally on these occasions
when we're we're looking at a future
olympics there's a number of bidding
cities they
have their final presentation on a day
like this and then a vote is made
that hasn't happened this time around
there's been a complete transformation
in the way
these 2032 games were distributed back
in february it was announced that uh
brisbane was the preferred bidder for
the ioc
and that meant that other interested
cities and nations including qatar
indonesia india there are also bids uh
percolating in spain and in germany
we're asked to sit on the sidelines
while the irc discussed with brisbane
how viable their bid was how sustainable
it was and how cost
efficient it could be because in their
eyes those are now the key
things uh heading into an olympic games
to try and use existing venues
and only to use venues that aren't going
to cost
huge amounts of money to the host nation
now
some arguments about a conflict of
interest here uh thomas back the money
put in charge of setting up what's
described as the future host commission
is john coates who is
uh by chance an australian one of his
closest allies a vice president within
the ioc a man who was behind organizing
the sydney 2000 games and
the man in charge of that host
commission being an australian and
funnily enough
here we are with uh with a host city
from australia so
some criticism about the transparency in
this process
and really a huge challenge ahead for
brisbane to make sure that these games
do stay uh sustainable and uh
economically viable
since 1976 in the games in montreal on
average
uh host cities go over budget by no less
than 230
so a huge challenge ahead for brisbane
a huge challenge ahead for brisbane and
arguably a huge challenge ahead for
tokyo
as well but more on that on the days and
weeks to come for now andy richardson
in tokyo thank you very much indeed